[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt ich
habe neulich eine richtig coole idee
gesehen of interest und zwar einen
krampf das ist ein rap und zwar wird der
ofen gebacken und der ist ziemlich krank
daher heißt also und ich habe mir dann
gedacht mensch da muss ich unbedingt mal
machen habe ein rezept dazu entwickelt
mit einer hackfleisch füllung mit
frischen tomaten avocados salat und
natürlich nachos die sorgen für den
crash und das ganze sieht richtig cool
aus vor allem ist es noch richtig tolle
große portion und wirklich einfach
zuzubereiten und auch vorzubereiten
und da steht schon startlöchern zum
probieren gerne unbedingt unbedingt und
ich zeige ich jetzt einfach mal die
zutaten für die füllung und dann gehts
auch gleich los für die hackfleischsoße
brauche ich 500 gramm hackfleisch eine
zwiebel dies bereits gewürfelt drei
esslöffel olivenöl einen esslöffel
tomatenmark 200 gramm passierte tomaten
etwa 100 milliliter wasser
ich habe ich noch die gewürze jeweils
einen teelöffel salz curry und chili
eine prise zucker und etwas pfeffer zum
befüllen brauche ich käse hier nämlich
jetzt einen käse aus kuhmilch mit etwa
60 prozent fertig habe ich noch einen
halben eisbergsalat zwei tomaten eine
avocado jeweils 150 gramm kidney bohnen
und mais aus der dose 200 gramm also
karstadt käse und hier habe ich noch 200
gramm nachos ich starte jetzt zuerst
mittag fleisch soße dafür gebe ich jetzt
das öl in einem großen topf und erhielt
zuerst bei mittlerer hitze
sobald das wird heiss ist kommt ihr
fleisch mit dazu und wird angebraten
es ist üblich ist
[Musik]
das hat vielleicht habe ich selber
gemacht und dafür einfach in den akten
genommen und den fleischwolf verwendet
[Musik]
jetzt kommen hier die zwiebelwürfel mit
dazu und werden für etwas zwei minuten
mit angebrachten
jetzt fühle ich hier das tomatenmark
dazu und früher ist kurz ein flasche
dann das hackfleisch mit den passierten
tomaten ab hier gebe ich jetzt noch das
wasser mehr dazu und lass es aufkochen
und gemeinsam mit den gewürzen und der
prise zucker einkochen für etwa fünf bis
zehn minuten und dafür stelle ich jetzt
auch die hilfe des herdes wieder
herunter
[Musik]
die zwischenzeit nutze ich jetzt um das
gemüse vorzubereiten
dafür nehme ich jetzt den eisbergsalat
dem schneide ich in feine streifen und
die tomaten und die avocado werde ich
fein würfeln
[Musik]
den salat werde ich nach dem waschen
schleudern damit das ganze wasser
natürlich auch wegkommt und nicht in
meinem crêpes landet
[Musik]
als nichts weil ich jetzt den käse
nehmen und den einfach mit den händen
ein bisschen zerbröseln
den gibt es übrigens in 60 prozent und
auch in 65 prozent stufe und je höher
der fettgehalt und so creme geister käse
und in diesem rezept pass deswegen
richtig gut denn in der füllung drinnen
kann da richtig toll schmelzen gibt die
würfe an die füllung ab und es schmeckt
später richtig gut
[Musik]
immer wieder einen kleinen meist die die
maus mit die meisten aus mit dem und als
nächstes schreibe ich jetzt noch den cut
käse den habe ich jetzt auch gerade noch
einen kühlschrank so lässt sich richtig
toll reiben und dafür nehme ich jetzt
einfach so eine stand reibe und waren
hier vorne diesen aufsatz drinnen und
dann bist du wirklich richtig aufpassen
die sind wirklich sehr scharf auf grund
des laser cut verfahrens und es ist
einfach im gegensatz zu anderen reiben
so dass die wirklich sehr langlebig sind
und das was man drin schneidet oder
reibt das wird einfach nicht zerrissen
sondern wirklich sehr glatt geschnitten
den habe ich jetzt hier auf dem
ceranfeld das ist eine tolle glatte
oberfläche kann das jetzt hier fest
spannen und hier oben fest wollen und
dann besitzt es wirklich bombenfest und
ich kann denn dort käse drin reifen
[Musik]
für mich ist es super praktisch denn
kann mich nicht dran schneiden und vor
allem finde ich ganz gut dass man
wirklich gar keine reste drinnen hat
jetzt habe ich alle zutaten vorbereitet
jetzt geht's am schichten ich nehme
jetzt einen großen gusseisernen topf ihr
könnt aber auch beispielsweise eine
pfanne nehmen die für den backofen
geeignet ist oder einfach eine andere
backform springform zum beispiel jetzt
nehme ich hier etwas olivenöl und
bestreicht die form damit jetzt habe ich
hier ein paar meistert hierfür sind
einfach meist laden die könnt ihr
entweder selbst machen oder auch fertig
kaufen
jetzt werde ich die form damit auslegen
und zwar überlappen
sechs stück habe ich jetzt hier aus nun
damit dass jetzt ein loch da kommt jetzt
noch ein portier rein
jetzt kommt zuerst der cremige weiss
käser unten rein
jetzt kommt die hälfte der hackfleisch
füllung rein
[Musik]
darüber die tomaten und die avocado
hilfe verteidigt noch den mais und die
bohnen darüber dann noch den salat
wie wird die nation
was die sorgen da drin dann für den
krampf und natürlich auch für ein
bisschen würze und diebe denke ich jetzt
mit dem restlichen hackfleisch und dann
mit dem café keese
[Musik]
genauso haben ihre hat recht jetzt kommt
noch mal ein tier fladen obendrauf und
jetzt glaube ich hier die seiten eins
und das ganze sieht er nicht richtig
hübsch aus
[Musik]
und jetzt bestreite ich den rap nur noch
mit etwas olivenöl kamerafrau sah mir
[Musik]
jetzt gut aus du machst das auch richtig
gut
und so kommt der kran treppe jetzt in
den vorgeheizten backofen bei 200 grad
ober unterhitze etwa 20 bis 25 minuten
[Musik]
so sieht der grand rapids aus sport
richtig coole perfekt richtig los das
jetzt mal den handschuh an damit ich
mich nicht verbrenne und schneide ihn
jetzt auch direkt so wie du bist wenn
wir das kann man von einem schiff was
ich gerade das mikrofon dranhängt wo du
das nächste mal hört es war okay was
gerade passiert
naja es war richtig grantig und du hast
noch richtig gehört wie sie es nicht
unten jetzt zur katja dies konkret
deinen teller und wie es aussieht als
würde ich gerade licht am ende des
tunnels sehen so ähnlich ist keiner hat
so viele instagram fotos reichen
das unter drin in blogs noch dass ich da
hamma dass ich einfach diese
gusseisernen topf kabelsalat auf aber
ich hab mir das nie gesehen dass man
salatbar mit braucht ja vor lecker was
ich auch den krieger sondern was ich
vergessen habe die sour cream aber ich
glaube die brauchen wir gar nicht weil
ich habe zwei käsesorten drin
hier verlaufen ist
das fleisch problem zwar ein problem
aber ich muss dazu sagen als inspiration
habe ich auch meine nacho salat genommen
der war ja schon so super witzig hier
habe ich jetzt allerdings keine chilis
mit drei sondern nur ein genie flocken
aber nicht zu schaffen ist wenn die
kegler des richtig cool verlaufen
machen wir das was einmalig das brot
oder was ich dass ich war die nachos
natürlichen das meistert er
und wie schmeckt würzig cremig lecker
und der salat schmeckt auch gut gell
ihnen dann hätte ich niemals wieder
werde ich niemals gedacht ich mache es
einfach mal mit rein und also ganz wilde
party macht und die bringt ist auch von
den party mit oder ihr macht es auch
noch party ihr seid gerade absolute kind
wirklich müsst ihr unbedingt machen
sondern richtig für die coolen
sommerparty oder richtig genial sind vor
allem die verbindung aus hackfleisch und
dem weichkäse richtig genial das perfekt
zusammen sieht auch toast mit butter und
weichkäse
wow werde ich nochmal zu bereiten und
vor allem werde ich auch mal eine andere
geschmacksrichtung machen
falls ihr das rezept jetzt auch gerne
nachmachen möchte schaut aufs ndr vorbei
und schauen uns jetzt motto will die
posen kann ich die ligna schickt nur so
vor mir das nachgemacht haben vorgemacht
jetzt auch nach warschau heiligen steht
schon in der küche hat schon probiert ob
es jetzt alle zutaten auf einmal findet
ja das stimmt das kann vielleicht ein
problem sein
und ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
namen richtig guten appetit und wir
sehen uns dann beim nächsten mal bis
dann also bei mir ich werde jetzt auch
ein stück abschneiden
und dann kommt eine ordentliche portion
tabasco drauf richtig lecker und chili
und alle hören
ich kann es war diesmal ehrlich sein
[Musik]